alors d'abord c'est quand on a le
capitaine des Bleus hein
jusqu'à Crystal Palace que ce qu'il
fasse
ses bêtises
alors Platini vous a dit un truc sur le
comment aller chercher un trophée moi
j'adore cette histoire c'est à qui vous
a dit qu'il faut prendre son temps il a
raison il m'a dit beaucoup de choses il
m'a dit ouais prends le temps parce que
c'est possible que tu reconnaisses pas
encore ce même plaisir
c'est souvent quand même mais bon il
faut prendre le plaisir parce que c'est
vraiment un plaisir d'arriver au bout de
gagner une coupe c'est beaucoup de
boulot c'est vrai que quand on reçoit un
trophée que vous aurez votre Molière
vous verrez quand on reçoit un trophée
on y va toujours en courant
il faut savourer tout à fait bon à part
ça bon tout le monde vous le dit quoi il
a il a pas été très sympa avec vous
Platini c'est ce qu'on me dit mais
pourquoi
je sais pas si c'est moi j'ai de bons
rapports avec lui pourtant c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte énormément que
j'ai jamais voulu critiquer parce que il
est pas criticable pour moi mais bon
pourtant quand je le vois quand il est
toujours le sourire quand même il la
ramène pas non je le chambre vraiment
un privé quoi je me gêne pas non plus
mais ça s'arrête là quoi alors il a dit
vous étiez un joueur peu spectaculaire
sans génie pas un grand joueur
il est jaloux parce qu'il a jamais eu la
Coupe du monde non c'est ça
j'espère pas si l'année a été jaloux
Platini par rapport à tout ce qu'il a
fait ça veut dire
d'autres joueurs qui soient aigri et
jaloux je peux le comprendre sans citer
de nom mais que Michel Platini soit
comme ça non pour moi c'est pas c'est
pas possible vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez parce que étudier le problème
pendant de longs mois
je suis d'accord avec moi bon après vous
êtes vendus à l'OM alors j'adore le
toujours le côté maquignon
on t'a vendu Didier ça sera à Marseille
ils avaient besoin d'argent l'époque ils
étaient en difficulté c'était le
président le regretté max Bouillet et il
m'a appris ça oui au soir d'un match en
équipe de France je joue à Toulouse
vendu voilà
vous arrivez à Marseille
alors lui en plus il croit pas en vous
sur au départ oui il vous a prêté à
Bordeaux oui après six mois après parce
que j'ai eu un départ fulgurant et puis
après un peu le trou noir
tu réussiras pas vaut mieux que tu
partes sympa
c'est ce qu'il pensait
quand il m'a redonné ma chance donc
c'est qu'au fond de lui
vous êtes battus j'ai discuté avec lui
pendant au moins une heure et demie je
me suis accroché au téléphone je dis
parce que pour moi à partir du moment
j'avais signé un contrat à l'OM il était
hors de question il fallait que je
m'impose alors ça c'était clair et donc
je suis revenu et puis mais après il m'a
facilité la tâche quand même il m'a
donné ma chance après vous imposé avec
deux Saïd d'ailleurs et puis vous
finissez capitaine et puis après la
Coupe d'Europe des clubs champions à
Munich
jusque là tout va bien au
prieuréa et puis l'histoire de la Coupe
du Monde 94 moi j'étais au Parc des
Princes malheureusement à quelle heure
je te jure on mettait les manteaux et à
ce moment-là
c'était terrible il y avait des gens qui
étaient pas en bleu blanc rouge comme ça
avec les larmes qui coulaient sur le
bleu blanc rouge et tout c'était une
image d'une force c'était terrible pour
vous mais pour nos joueurs
de ma carrière
et là comme par hasard c'est bon on peut
pas aller plus bas donc c'est le début
de la remontée avec avec Jacquet alors
d'abord c'est cantonal capitaine des
Bleus
comme footballeur comme être humain
comme acteur il me fait marrer
et de l'Espagne différent comme ami des
mouettes aussi
votre charisme et puis vous remplacez
donc quand on a disons qu'il a eu des
discussions avec
Eric Cantona il avait des choix à faire
et à partir du moment où il a pas pris
Eric il a dû s'appuyer sur sur une autre
personne il a fait le tour un peu des
anciens et puis il m'a confié le
brassard de capitaine
il était dans une fête il a fait attendu
Jacquet pendant deux heures donc c'est
vrai
remplace quand on a papa sur l'Euro 96
et la grande équipe de France se met peu
à peu près et non pas le fait que je
sois moi capitaine
quand on a je sais pas vous qui les fait
virer quand même non j'ai pas ce pouvoir
là non
pour lui pendant 5 ans donc
ça c'est sûr non mais bon on était non
mais même moi qui n'aime pas le football
du tout je me suis prise genre
demi-finales et tout ça klaxonné dans la
voiture comme une andouille alors que
j'aurais trouvé ça stupide six mois
avant et c'est vraiment on était tous
avec vous pourquoi tous les gens étaient
réunis
à la presse le championnat d'Europe
critiques les critiques je les ai
toujours accepté elles font partie du
métier comme on dit mais lorsqu'on en
arrive à ce que ça soit des articles
malsains ou avoir jusqu'à l'incompétence
bon ça ne m'intéressait pas de répondre
à certaines personnes malheureusement
c'était pas la majorité des journalistes
et je le regrette pour lui dire
en particulier
qui ont cherché à la victoire que vous
aviez obtenue avec l'équipe de France à
la Coupe du Monde comment dans les
années qui ont suivi vous pouvez être
autant critiqué les Guignols qu'on va
mettre une couche comme le dissip bien
aimé Jacquet comment non mais comment ça
se fait comment vous expliquer ça à vous
l'image des Guignols parce que j'avais
pas quelque chose de particulier qui
pouvait me faire entrer dans le mien
mais je crois pas que je l'ai dit
souvent cette phrase Aimé Jacquet
heureusement l'a dit lui-même c'est vrai
que j'ai souvent eu des accrochages avec
lui parce qu'on n'était pas forcément
d'accord mais bon c'est pas bien méchant
mais les critiques c'est comme ça on a
été champion du monde et on a une une
période de qualification pour l'Euro qui
a été très difficile où on nous disait
il fallait changer tout le monde et il y
avait que des donneurs de leçons les
mêmes qui avaient critiqué avant la
Coupe du Monde et après ils étaient
obligés de reconnaître que c'était quand
même un bon entrepreneur et vous
oui le maire évidemment dans la lignée
du Jacquet et puis certainement moi
aussi parce que bon j'étais un peu le
l'héritier de Jacquet on était blessé
par les propos d'un coéquipier qui a dit
en parlant de vous Didier il est cramé
et le 2 septembre votre dernier match
donc vous allez le voir et vous lui
dites je sais exactement les propos que
tu as tenu sur moi
c'est un des joueurs non j'ai pas envie
le fait que je me sois éliminé c'est à
dire que j'ai laissé l'équipe de France
ça pose plus aucun problème vu que bon
il peut continuer moi je continue pas si
j'avais eu à continuer ça aurait
certainement poser des problèmes parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui qui m'a trahi et
j'aime pas ça surtout de l'Intérieur
lui aussi il le sait puisque je lui ai
dit et vous moi j'ai mis huit mois avant
de le savoir mais je vais vous le dire
c'est
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu